hi my name is Maxime I'm a student in
computer science in Stanford I was
fortunate enough to take the live
version of this course in Stanford
looking back I think it's the best class
I took in Stanford and here are five
reasons why so the first reason is that
the process we learn is extremely
practical we actually learn how to build
a company from scratch
and go through all the steps of the
process that will lead you to raise
money from investors and in real life
that is exactly what you are expected to
go through if you want to actually start
a company and so every year you know
this is so realistic that some startups
actually get launched after the class
they raise money they build products and
in some cases they're extremely
successful second point is that everyone
can learn from this class no matter what
your background is business engineering
medicine if you want to build a tech
startup you will learn something out of
this class so the speakers in this class
are absolutely amazing they have all
built led to companies you can check
their names on Google they advise invest
in superstar startups and the advice
they give in this class is the fruit of
decades of experience so that is
extremely valuable that we without any
particular background in how the launch
companies can directly learn from people
who are superstars in the field so this
course gives you an unfiltered view of
how things work in the tech startup
ecosystem you get to understand how
investors reason what their mindset is
what they're looking for what they care
in your business and getting to know how
it works behind the scenes is extremely
valuable because in real life it's
usually hard to get that unbiased vision
of what someone is looking for in your
business and your product what he's
worried about and and this is I think
the major one of the major strengths of
this course
finally mentors in this class are
fantastic their advice is extremely
valuable as they have they were in your
shoes a few years before when they were
themselves launching their own company I
used to think that starting a tech
company was only for other people and
after taking this class I felt confident
enough that I can do it
[Music]